alright uh Hank certainly be waiting i
do have your lab results here and yes
it's part of the job i hate i am afraid
i have a bit of bad news we can
certainly fix this problem the bad news
is it's going to cost about 22 23
thousand dollars even if you have
insurance I do yeah still still a lot of
money and I think it's time we seriously
talked about the option of putting you
to sleep I don't mean to be callous I
know these choices can be difficult
there's no way we're doing that it's not
a hard choice to make but uh you know
maybe we could find another another one
just like you nobody there orange find
another orange cat person and then
nobody would notice you know maybe at
first it would be a little weird small
differences small coloration differences
behavior but after a while maybe maybe
people would just get used to it and
even if they did even if they did figure
it out we could always just say that you
had to go to a special farm special
special farm for cats where every day
you just eat eat cream Bulls cream and
catch mice and run in the field doesn't
that doesn't that sound nice go to a
special if you go to a special farm for
for good cat that's where you would we
could tell everybody there's no way
we're doing that
I want the surgery okay I hear what
you're saying I understand if you want
to throw down that kind of cash uh I'm
sure we could do the happen give a PPO
or